let's go quickly with our science critic
uh here it is give me a second here I'm
going to put them on he's going to argue
that mathematics is indispensable it's
uh it's a requirement of physics okay
and I'm going to argue exactly the
opposite mathematics has nothing to do
with physics or with science so here
goes okay give me a second I'll put them
on
okay there we go
in this rebuttal we will address the
issue of whether we need math in physics
mmm
that was very stupid thing to say Bill
mess is pretty much Essential for
physics if you don't have maths you
don't have visits there is a reason why
Newton invented calculus in fact if you
have two competing hypotheses how do you
tell them apart well that will be done
using maths
okay so Phil says that uh the way they
prove hypothesis in mathematical physics
or in his version of science is by using
math okay uh first we have a difference
in the word hypothesis it has nothing to
do with Theory hypothesis is not a
theory uh in mathematical physics a
hypothesis is an unproven or a tentative
Theory that's not what it is in real
science and science hypothesis are the
objects the definitions and the
statement of the facts in other words
the first frames of the movie then from
there you build your theory okay so we
have a difference there uh but let's get
to the word math is math part of uh
physics is math part of science well in
order to do that you have to Define what
science is and what physics is and
that's where the problem is these people
have never defined the word physics in a
rational manner they haven't defined the
word science in a rational manner they
think that science is just a series of
descriptions and we're saying science is
explanations not descriptions we have a
difference there and this is the rundown
here real quick science rational
explanations physics rational
explanations of what causes and
mechanisms we have to have an
explanation of mechanisms of causes
that's what we don't have today and you
might say well I don't agree with your
definition Bill okay no problem the
issue is the following uh I'm going to
ask you a question I'm going to say is
uh explaining how this magnet attracts
that other magnet right
is that a question of physics according
to you
do you think this is part of the subject
matter of physics explaining how it is
that when magnet attracts another for
example is this part of physics yes if
you say that this is a question that
physics has to answer that it is a
question of physics
your the definition we have today of
Science in a physics does not address
these types of questions the
mathematical physicists and the
scientists so-called scientists they say
these questions are questions of
philosophy and philosophy is outside the
bounds of physics and of science because
it is the mother of all sciences and
blah blah blah and so this is not a
question that physics answers that's
what the problem is so we have
irrational explanations for example that
web space is gravity uh that a particle
can be in two places at once and when
you say well that's irrational and they
say well yeah because that's philosophy
and we don't care and that's not part of
science
but that's the questions that the type
of questions people ask for example in
quora they say how does a magnet attract
another and you have all these
mathematical physics that come in there
and they say well here's the equation
this is the uh force with which one
magnet attracts another well that's not
the question I'm asking I'm asking what
is the physical mechanism of how a
magnet attracts another and you won't
find an answer to those questions
because they don't consider it part of
physics part of science that's where the
problem is and so again if mathematics
uh I'm sorry physics is rational
explanations of causes and mechanisms
that covers all physics and if that's
the case we don't need in for an
explanation we don't need math at all no
no numbers no math no equations no
functions we don't need any of that
because with that you cannot explain and
in physics and science is about
explaining you cannot explain with math
you can only describe with math okay
that's the issue you don't like my
definition come up with a better
mousetrap Give me a definition that you
can sink your teeth into don't copy it
from the dictionary don't Trends don't
transcribe it don't copy paste come up
with a definition that you can defend
for physics and then we'll find out if
mathematics has anything at all to do
with physics you can't use l30 you can't
use tradition you can't use democracy
you can't say that's the way we always
did it you can't say everybody in the
universe believes in my version you
can't say any of that and you can't say
well that's what I was taught in college
or in high school Authority you can't
use any of those come up with a
definition that you can defend okay so
um how does math uh explain gravity for
example how gravity works well you can't
do it with math you can only tell me how
strong gravity is maybe but you cannot
tell me what caused it with an equation
that's why math has nothing to do with
physics physics is explaining physics is
not doing an equation that describes
what happened okay
um so mathematical physics is an
oxymoron because math describes physics
explains never the twin shall meet okay
you're trying to unite two things that
are incompatible uh math is description
and physics is explanation